president trump is also significantly
changing his tone on the use of mask
yesterday at his first virus task force
briefing in almost three months
the president pulled a mask out of his
pocket he now says that he does carry
one and wears it
when he needs to and tracy's at the
white house with more on this story ben
that was a bit of a surprise when he put
pulled it out because he's made it clear
he doesn't really like wearing them so
why the about face do you think well the
president has seen the polls that show
that most americans don't approve of how
he's handled the virus and that it could
cost him the election
so in these new briefings he's now a
one-man show
with a more somber tone
it will probably unfortunately get worse
before it gets better
the president is now acknowledging the
obvious coronavirus is surging across
the country
not fading away you've been saying for
months the virus would simply disappear
and now you're saying that it's likely
to get worse before it gets better
if it does keep getting worse if
americans keep dying
are you responsible for that well the
virus will disappear
the governors are working with me i'm
working with the governor we're working
hand in hand i think we're all
responsible the president says he's now
open to expanding testing
even though just days ago his
administration was fighting against new
funding for it
democrats did not welcome his return to
the podium
it was weird because a briefing on the
coronavirus should be about
science and that is something the
president has ignored
i think a good deal of what we have
suffered is clearly
the trump virus members of the trump
administration spent tuesday on capitol
hill
negotiating a fourth round of
coronavirus stimulus
republicans want a one trillion dollar
package including funding for schools
and tax credits for businesses democrats
favor a more expansive
three trillion dollar stimulus with aid
to states
and an extension of the 600 weekly
unemployment benefit
both sides do support stimulus checks
though it's not clear how much would be
sent out
and who would be eligible there is
little support in either party for
president trump's call for a payroll tax
cut
we're still in discussion with the
administration on that
the president was forced off script at
one point on tuesday when he was asked
about
elaine maxwell the associate of jeffrey
epstein she is currently in jail
awaiting charges of sexual abuse
which she denies in a strange moment the
president said that he has met her
numerous times
and he wishes her well anthony a very
strange moment ben thank you